we have the second sword piece
where should i remember a glow that must
be worse ah
brilliant
oh there she goes again were i not a
happily married man i'd let her take me
on an adventure
i need a fairy to wear them i will take
you
but beware smoke rises from the village
they're destroying the town get out
while you can
to those who defy the power
please my family's hiding the chapel
with the rest of the townsfolk we must
get
you cannot keep the sword from me this
is bad
my servants will burn this town to ashes
there's something coming
more fury no way
[Music]
the ancients have blessed me an
incredible
feat you say this i seek the health of a
son we found it days ago
come i left virgil to guard it i'm going
back to tristram to check on uncle
decker
damn it's not here
on your hero's errand here i captured
all three sword pieces and your
i should have known i must get back to
kane's house
it's your choice kane either use your
haradric
arch to repair the sword or your dear
leah
dies a horrible death
all this pain this destruction
what is the sword to you
to me nothing to my master
belial everything
your rage is overwhelming girl you win
this round
but if the sword cannot be mine
i'll claim the one to know in the end
the blade shall be mine
uncle you can't die
nothing can stop that now
but there is one last thing i must do
the sword must be made
whole
just as i suspected the sword
is of the high heavens the stranger
is an angel heed the journal
the truth lies
within
foreign